yellow heaven it's your old pal
Trevor permit oh my lord of the name old
pal jumper but how you doing sir I got
an idea everything about putting Jay and
Silent Bob in a video dude dude Osborne
our product but it wasn't last Friday
every live long day I've been alive I
think about putting James on the bottom
wanted a video games let me tell you yes
terra firma
what the [ __ ] is a video game anyway uh
well it's a game you play with a
controller alright we just call that
foosball oh I love dock use ball Trevor
Fuhrman we can make it like hockey
foosball the video game yep go on hold
on Trevor firm and somebody try and ring
through talking about making a J and
sound Bob video game how the [ __ ] would
you know that let me ask you another
thing smartass what the [ __ ] is a video
game I don't know dude it's a game with
a controller dumbass like foosball hey
look don't ever try to keep anything
like this from me again alright I have
beers and tell Trevor to make my guy
like Mega Man needs to be huge
sounds like Jays in although with one
caveat so you gotta make his character
look like a makeup man yeah we can do
that you got any requests make my
character beat up Bruce Willis I don't
think we can afford is like this I'm
just in Woodward creative director of
interrobang entertainment and the
founder of the media India exchange
I'm Trevor Furman you might remember me
from such films as clerks too and
actually it's possibly you don't
remember me from clerks too we have it
still
I met me from the meadow my nephew's
baptism I've been watching view askew
movies for a long-ass time the idea of
making a game based on the characters
and humor from the view askew universe
really gets me gooey in the gumdrops our
story takes place in New Jersey Jay and
Silent Bob really really wanted Orange
Julius but they've been banned from all
the nearby malls on a kind of loitering
and selling pot to minors as they reach
the mall in a neighboring town it
becomes clear that something is terribly
wrong
it's a side-scrolling beat-em-up with
deep tag-team fighting game mechanics
it's important to ask that people who
haven't played a game in a while or even
ever will be able to work their way
through the story while more experienced
players will have the option to really
sink their teeth into the system a big
part of the view askew universe is the
dialogue we really wanted to translate
that into a game so instead of having
Jay blurting out obscenities randomly
we're building a conversation system
that feels like a fighting game think of
it like Street Fighter but instead of
throwing a hot do looking to lower your
enemy's health bar
you're throwing obscenities to lower
your enemy's self-worth as in these we
could do what we want with the
narratives and themes in our games
something that publishers really don't
want to take a risk on like sex and
drugs for example big publishers tend to
think of it like this chainsaw mailman
in half and wear his corpse as a
disguise while you slowly infiltrate his
family sell it at Walmart taste will
side boob in a pot leaf t-shirt
adults-only [ __ ] not that we
have anything against gut churning
violence oh no no no no no Lord no we
love gut churning violence we just also
like side boob in pot we don't want to
give everything away just yet
but we think we've got a really great
story and a really great game to build
on now we just need to find a way to
convince you the audience that we're
worth supporting hey guys
legendary game designer Fergus Earhart
please gentlemen it's legendary game
designer mr. Akaka what are you doing
here
whenever inspiring game designers are
need I show up oh and you're in my
office in your way of my pinball machine
legendary game designer mr. Urquhart
you have one of the most successful
crowdfunding campaigns ever can you give
us any advice on arms first off you have
to spend decades and decades
growing a network and community of
people that are going to support you
over what I'm doing like the next two
and a half minutes well you need to
establish your setting which means you
gotta take everything you've been
thinking about and doing both the last
ten or 20 years and create a token s
world and then really flesh that out our
game takes place in a mall in New Jersey
says happy elves mall Santas have elves
close enough the progress everything
according to plan yeah but do they
suspect anything
yeah they suspect anything we make the
plans the puppets dance as they say yeah
cuz the game gonna be as good as they
say
Audrey's clear they're the chosen ones
they're gonna make the greatest game
mankind has ever known filled with our
subliminal messages deliciously diabolic
oh yeah deliciously diabolical hey what
are subliminal messages again wait you
guys didn't come up with a subliminal
messages Kevin was your job
oh my job was to explain an exactly what
a subliminal message is oh and my job
was to get cigar smoking and not inhale
mm-hmm damn it you guys